hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to little bug okay am I
supposed to use a gamepad or can I use a
keyboard for this morning now this is
just a demo of a game that's either
upcoming or I don't know how old the
demo is so it might oh whoa I don't know
what just happened but it was magical
and I loved it oh can I jump oh okay
whoa oh that's cool
okay so oh okay so I got to control them
independent Wow that is that is
sensitive and also did something happen
there's a rather sinister connotation to
this and I'm not sure what the hell is
going on here but it seems that you just
got in a car accident right bumper oh oh
that's cool that's that's really cool we
yeah oh that's so cool oh I love it I
love it a lot okay anyway so carrying on
aside from my ability to oh that could
have been instant death or probably not
I doubt that they would have killed this
look at what I can only assume is little
child I don't know but this is awesome I
love the way the light works it's so
cool
it's one of those cool things and I'm
gonna say is cool lot okay so what was
the point of going down here I'm
supposed to fall through whee oh boy
jumping into the unknown
forever and ever ever Oh Oh ahh Oh
that'll break it instantly okay so I
think that was the lesson it was about
to teach me right here
whoa boo ski oop not high enough okay
I'm a little longer qualms I am okay so
can I jump
can i who needs to jump when you have a
magical very following you around it's
my version of Navi oh I see can't fool
me I got it
man this is some inch it's it's
fascinating mechanics here there's some
really cool stuff at play
we ah see bam and we're out of the woods
I don't know what kind of mystical demon
put those magical barriers there or why
you have magic inside of your soul but
it's a fascinating experience and I
can't wait to see more of it but sadly
this is another game where it's just a
demo I've been playing a lot of these
demo games and I want the full versions
I want it all
Oh give it to me hello hi I just noticed
you in the background this must be some
kind of magical world because I don't
know why that would be just freely
allowed to roam around but that seems
like it might be some kind of bad my
first instinct is bad trail closed Tahoe
don't you know who I am even I don't
know who I am
wha boo ski whee well that didn't quite
work I think I was on the right track
okay huh you think I'm moving puzzle is
gonna be any sort of a oops there's got
to be any sort of a problem for me I
think not
what's with the flower whoa press X wha
flowers are the prettiest yeah I guess
and I whoa hey grabby hands yeah that's
uh that's really sinister why
oh man that's that's lit I know my god
she exploded he I don't know I can't
tell oh man well I gotta watch the
momentum on swinging this poor child
there's Navi suddenly regretted when her
her ward exploded on her press X I
wonder who this belongs to
I don't know oh wait did I not pick up
the other thing but I didn't pick up the
other thing goddammit I gotta go all the
way back while hopscotching we whoa ah
haha I found a secret there we go
okay I don't know why that didn't go
before huh huh huh huh oh god damn but I
thought I was skilled oh well I appeared
here anyway so I guess it's all good
well booze geek whoops no oh okay we're
fine
oh so that can't touch that either hey I
went right into it right into it okay
this now we're getting complicated hit
no okay almost did it whoa grab hands
whoo grabby grabby grabby no no no
that's a bad grabby whoa whoa whoa oh
[ __ ] we're there we're here sorry
a wild fungus my favorite Oh
I'm possibly insinuating that this kid
might have been doing drugs but then
again I don't know I don't know if this
is actually a child at all gosh she's
bloated he I don't know I can't tell yep
okay so what I gotta do is I gotta walk
down and then Hey right here yeah ah
sailed right into the abyss my goodness
here we go a little more conscious like
huh
there we go that's less death oh boy is
that a spider er I bet that's your
favorite as well we cool a spider oh it
looks so happy in my little terrarium
here
oh no it's crying Oh boohoo ah [ __ ]
is it crying over my death probably yeah
it yeah whoa ha ha ha ha I've got the
skill and the power and the thrill he
okay no dad didn't go as I planned it
yeah [ __ ] ah oceans explosions of the
meat forge here are you yeah I wouldn't
have been able to do this with a
keyboard this would have been very very
very difficult to hang here yeah okay we
got it
nope hang on
yep there we go get along get along get
along Go Go Go Go yes don't be sad I
found a pretty Rock Oh
[Music]
oh okay you mean a priceless gemstone
probably
oh whoops whoop ass [ __ ] so I need to go
up this is gonna be hard
whoop whoop whoop okay yeah huh okay
yeah yeah oh oh oh yeah yeah oh come on
I was just I couldn't do the thing ha ha
Oh rest huh oh ah ah
grabby hands there's gonna be hard no
don't look at that I don't care about
that
look at you say you don't care about
that yah ha ha
oh yes Wow Mama's favorite flower okay
what what I question is whether now
whether all this is a fever dream
because it seemed like she was in a car
accident of some ho oh okay
goodbye where did I go my fire Flyers
gone now I miss it very dearly where did
it go
oh hi how are you oh okay oh you've got
a lovely smile I'll just be on my way
over here well apparently and that's the
demo that was amazing I love that that's
really cool I want more gimme gimme
gimme
I can't wait oh boy oh boy I want to see
more of that I really really do I really
really do that was cool great concept
great game mechanic I love it a lot
challenging cool art style all the above
so either way thank you everybody so
much for watching check out this game
through the link in the description
below and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye